pastor skeet growing up my t my parents taught
me that the bible said that christians shouldn't
wear too much makeup and no jewelry at all but
being a rebellious child i found texts that
proved my parents wrong like the father of the
prodigal son putting a ring on his son's finger
kings of israel wearing crowns and
other and other texts like that
pastor skeet i'm not trying to hurt my
parents i just feel that they are being
a little too legalistic on my taste in fashion
what do you in the bible have to say about this
well i have nothing to say i'll
tell you what the bible has to say
with respect to the prodigal son which is
found in luke chapter 15 verse 11 to 32
if you read the text in the context of the culture
then you'll understand that when the bible says
and put a ring on his hand and shoes on his feet
the ring was not a piece of jewelry in today's
world when we want to make a document official
what do we do we sign in those days the signature
was a mark it was a seal that was affixed to
a clear tablet usually made of wax or some
impressionable material which would subsequently
harden and render that mark of authority permanent
and so what the father was demonstrating was
his total reception of that boy back into his
household and so by giving him the ring he gave
him the symbol of authority to transact business
it was not a piece of outward decoration i
have a pen right in this pocket here with
which i sign what i have to sign back then the
pen was worn right here it was not decoration
it was an official document an official
instrument for making documents valid
now in daniel 6 verse 17 when daniel was put
into the lion's den the bible says and a stone
was brought and laid upon the mouth of the
den and the king sealed it with his own signet
and with the signet of his lords the signet
was again the official sign so when the king
sealed that tomb it meant no one was to open
that tomb and release daniel he sealed it with
his own signet which he carried when
judah had that adulterous affair with
a woman who you thought was a prostitute
not knowing she was his daughter-in-law
he had no money at the time to pay this prostitute
and she said well leave me something as some sort
of assurance that when you come back you'll pay
me and one of the things he left was his signet
tremendous thing to leave so when he went
back several months later and the girl had
removed her prostitute disguise and he
had found out that she had sinned she
had gotten pregnant for him he didn't know it
he went out to kill her we must kill sinners
so when he went to get her by the scruff
of the neck she presented to him the signet
and his heart broke because he recognized
that this thing she had represented him
and he said she is more righteous than i am
in genesis 35 reading from verse 1
the bible says and god said unto jacob
arise go up to bethel and make there an altar unto
god that appeared unto thee when thou fled us from
the face of thy brother esau and in verse 2 the
bible says then jacob spake unto his household and
to all that were with him and said put away the
strange gods that are among you and be clean and
change your garment now in verse 4 the text goes
on to say and they gave unto jacob all the strange
gods that which were in the hands and all the
earrings which were in the ears and that simply
represents everything earrings whatever hangs here
here from around the ankles the back of your neck
wherever you have them gave them up the bible
says and jacob hid them under the tree which was
by shechem because god said purify yourself now
you're going up to bethel bethel means house of
god jacob had finally settled the dispute with
esau they put the way they buried the hatchet
so to speak we have in verse chapter 34 the story
of dinah who was written by the shekhamite prince
now with 35 god is saying a different stage in
your life come to shechem to battle the house of
god make an altar you're coming to worship now
with all the baggage of the past removed clean
yourself and part of the cleaning of the self is
the removal of that which god did not put on us
when he made us in uh revelation chapter 12 verse
one the bible says and they and they appeared of
great wonder in heaven a woman clothed with the
sun and the moon under her feet and upon her head
a crown of twelve stars this woman represents
the true church and all that makes her shine
and glitter comes from outside of her are
you following me that which makes her glitter
comes from outside of her now look at the other
woman in revelation the only two revelation 17
verse four and the woman was arrayed in purple
and scarlet color that's the that's the [ __ ] and
decked with gold precious stones and pearls having
a golden cup in her hand full of abominations and
filthiness of fornication there are two women
in revelation one represents the true church
and that which covers her was put on her by
god is the light of the gospel of jesus christ
the gospel must be seen in how we look
the woman representing the false church
is decked because she decked herself gold
now the word death means i mean decked out
gold and precious stones and pearls her beauty
comes from the earth that's where gold comes from
precious stones and pearls the light of the true
church comes from the sun which is from above
the moon from above and the stars from
above when adam and eve sinned the first
act the first creation of man was
something to put on the outside
the first act of creation by human beings was
something to improve the way they looked on the
outside to fix up to to give a false
appearance to what was on the inside
when god came genesis 3 21 he removed it and
so genesis 3 21 says unto adam also unto his
wife did the lord god make what coats of skins and
clothe them now they were literal quotes of skins
but because there were skins it meant
someone had to die something the animals
died representing jesus christ when we dress
somehow we must reflect the plan of salvation
we must look like those for whom jesus shed
his blood god removed what they made themselves
and he put on them that which would ever
remind them of the sacrifice that would be made
four thousand years later in dress in
eating in recreation in everything we do
christ must be seen in us i was conducting a
crusade i'm taking a lot of time for this is
serious because today is the last day i was doing
a crusade in the country won't say which one and
uh in the hotel where i stayed after leaving the
crusade preaching counseling i'd get back to the
hotel 11 o'clock at night or 10 30. and that time
of the night the ladies of the night came out
you know who the ladies of the night are it's
not there's a plan to the west indies called
lady of the night i'm not referring to that plan
they came out and they were dressed a certain way
tight pants
law blouses
why it was part of the business to advertise
a prostitute knows if you want to catch a man
give him a peep no just let him get a
peek that's how you generate business
you've never seen a prostitute wearing a whole
long gown and her face covered up no she'll
be out of business that same day they do not
dress like that they dress to generate business
let's be honest now i'd go to the tent to do the
crusade and the ladies from the local churches
some of them they dress the same way so i said
from the pulpit wait a minute stop confusing me
i want to be sure that the women outside
my hotel they are there to sell something
and so they advertise now i don't want to
think that of you i have to assume that's
not your purpose but you are doing the same
thing in a certain sense you are advertising
no one dresses scantily accidentally
you look in your closet and you say two
motivations you have in mind not a woman but
let me tell you what i've seen and learned
two motivations in the mind of a woman one
i need to outdress the other women
i don't expect amens don't give me them
i need to look better than other women
a woman's first concern is not to dress for a man
but to look better than other women now motivation
too just in case that doesn't work let me make
sure something is showing that accomplishes
what i have in mind attract somebody's
attention i was listening to two women
at my church back in wherever i'm from i won't
mention that church either and one was advising
the other one how to get a husband i'm not
joking she said girl that dress is too long
she said what you're wearing is too loose
she said tighten it up so the men can see
now this is very serious in genesis
chapter 4 the story of cain and abel
seven times we're told that abel was his
brother it's the only place in scripture
where we have the birth of siblings and we're
kept we're told over and over his brother his
brother meaning we have a responsibility for
one another men are affected by what they see
you come to church dress any way you like and
men have a hard time focusing on the gospel
not because they're not children of god
but because they're made a certain way
instead of you know one of these days
melinda started doing all the health studies
do a survey of what goes on in the mind of a man
when a woman in tight pants walks
by do that survey you'll be shocked
do it anonymously of course
you will be shocked at what honest men will say
now again a thought in the mind is not sin it
goes into the mind you hit it with some
scripture and you move on with your life
but it makes it difficult for men and
men be careful what you say to women
there's a reason why pornography
is largely directed at men
naked magazines men you think
cheerleaders are there for women
cheerleaders on those professional teams are for
men and cheerleaders do not wear long dresses
let's be honest christians they are from men
professional skating you see women in long dresses
no men would come to the show short things
that fly up men come they pay for that
men watch what you say to women it's 11
39 but you don't have to go to work watch
what you say because ellen white says the
devil knew he could go get adam one on one
he could get eve for some reason god made us
differently and i'm glad he did women will women
have to talk things out a man he's done with it
i'm done and you haven't started but he's done
a woman you have to discuss it so she
sees where every dot goes over the eye
and every cross goes over the
t so then her mind is clear
the devil knew that he said don't let me
waste my time with adam that man won't talk
i need someone who will talk and he got the woman
and she talked her way right into
trouble and women still do that today
many women find themselves involved with
other men because they felt they had to
explain to one man why they love
somebody else no don't explain
stop talking so much